will Black Adam and Shazam ever Clash on
screen it has almost happened a couple
of times but one person stood in the way
Dwayne Johnson here's why I put the
kibosh on this Clash of the Titans the
2022 release of Black Adam was a
culmination of years of production
beginning with Dwayne Johnson being cast
in the titular role all the way back in
2007. Black Adam's arrival on the big
screen was preceded by the 2019 film
Shazam that film followed the story of a
foster child named Billy Batson who gets
infused with superpowers including
flight and invulnerability by a wizard
in the comics Shazam and Black Adam are
Arch enemies who got their powers from
the same Source but opted for different
paths afterward I kneel before no one
with both characters now officially in
the DC extended Universe many comic book
fans have been eager to see the two
square off against one another but it
appears that confrontation isn't
happening anytime soon Johnson is
reportedly next to planned Black Adam
appearance in the Shazam sequel Shazam
Fury of the Gods film reporter Umberto
Gonzalez tweeted using Johnson's
nickname Rock passed on doing a cameo
and Shazam 2 when he was asked Johnson's
decision isn't necessarily a surprise he
doesn't seem to be big on the character
of Shazam despite his historical
connection to Black Adam the 2019 film
Shazam was poised to introduce Black
Adam in a scene where the newly
superpowered members of the Shazam
family sat on their Thrones before
realizing there was a seventh seed that
sat empty the rap reported that Johnson
quashed the scene as well as any other
reference to Black Adam in the film and
an August 2022 Vanity Fair interview
Johnson confirmed that Black Adam
originally had a prominent part in
Shazam he noted that the script
originally served as an origin story for
both characters but he wasn't open to
such an arrangement he explained when I
read that I just knew in my gut we can't
make this movie like this we would be
doing Black Adam and incredible
disservice it would have been fine for
Shazam having two Origin stories
converge in one movie but not good for
Black Adam Johnson said that he made a
call to Warner Brothers Executives and
insisted they separate the characters
allowing Shazam to develop its own tone
independent to Black Adam the hierarchy
of power in the DC Universe
is about to change fandom wire caught up
with Zachary Levi who plays Shazam at
Comic-Con Portugal in December 2022 and
asked him about whether Black Adam and
Shazam would meet on screen Levi
responded that he has no idea whether
the two characters would get a chance to
interact and has no influence over how
the story would play out it did
playfully point out though that if he
had the opportunity to punch Dwayne
Johnson in the face he would take it The
Hollywood Reporter called a sequel to
Black Adam unlikely now that James Gunn
and Peter Safran have taken over as the
new heads of DC Studios it's one of a
slate to planned projects that two have
reportedly scrapped while on stage at
Comic-Con Portugal Levi was asked about
his own character's cinematic future
Levi responded that gun and saffron are
friends of his and joked that friendship
would be in Jeopardy if they didn't have
Shazam as a part of their plans for DC
going forward in an interview with
collider Shazam and Shazam Fury the gods
director David F Sandberg was also asked
about plans for Black Adam and Shazam to
interact in future films he responded
that he has not been involved in any
conversations about the two characters
coming face to face adding that both
characters were on their own
trajectories at the moment
[Music]